by en allemagne depuis il ce matin le
port du masque est désormais obligatoire
dans les commerces l'allemagne où le
nombre de cas de contamination a grimpé
à plus de 150 7600 le pays redoutent une
deuxième vague de l'épidémie les
précisions de rania berrada même si elle
continue d'être cité en exemple pour sa
gestion de la crise l'allemagne fait
face aux premiers signes d'aggravation
de l'épidémie sur son sol selon les
chiffres publiés lundi soir par
l'institut robert koch chargé de
surveiller l'évolution du virus
son taux de reproduction est en hausse
il atteint de nouveau un seuil de 1,0
outre rats et fait craindre une
saturation des hôpitaux à court terme
avec un taux d'infection à 1,1 nous
pourrions atteindre les limites de notre
système de santé en termes de lit en
réanimation d'ici octobre avec un taux à
1,2 nous atteindrons les limites de
notre système de santé en juillet avec
un taux à 1,3 nous y arriverons déjà en
juin
cette hausse du taux de reproduction
confirme les craintes de la chancelière
allemande qui redoute un déconfinement
trop rapide et plaide pour des mesures
plus restrictives
car depuis le 20 avril l'allemagne a
commencé à alléger progressivement ces
restrictions
en rouvrant notamment certains magasins
ainsi que des collèges et lycées l'autre
signal alarmant et celui du taux de
létalité lui aussi en hausse
il se situe désormais à 3 8% est même
s'il reste inférieur aux pays voisins
les autorités allemandes exhortent la
population à la prudence
viral winshluss à tous les twittos nous
souhaitons tous bien sûr plus de
normalité un retour à la normalité mais
nous devons faire en sorte surtout dans
un contexte d'allègement des mesures de
continuer à défendre ce succès commun
nous devons veiller ensemble à ce que
nous n'ayons pas à nouveau plus de cas
plus d'infections et par conséquent plus
de malades graves
si cette tendance à la hausse devait se
confirmer elle pourrait compliquer les
efforts des autorités d'un retour
progressif à la normale alors que
l'impatience de l'opinion grandit le
gouvernement fédéral
les régions allemandes qui ont le
dernier mot en matière de santé doivent
discuter des prochaines étapes du
déconfinement jeudi avant des décisions
attendues le 6 mai on est